one of the things that I think
Republicans really would be good at is
putting out a positive message what is
it that we stand for well McCarthy's on
that too Republicans are going after an
army that doesn't exist this is Theater
tonight Mr Speaker for months a
smattering of fact checks have debunked
GOP claims the money will be used to
hire 87 000 IRS employees many of whom
won't be badge toting agents but rather
I.T and customer service professionals
the new hires will also be a backstop as
the IRS expects to lose some 50 000
workers over the next five years the
Biden Administration hasn't determined
exactly how it plans to spend the 80
billion dollars in new funding but just
over half of the money is aimed at
enforcement those IRS agents would be
set up to go after hard work and
families across this country treasury
secretary Jenny yellin says that's not
true I've directed that enforcement
resources will will not be used to raise
audit rates for households making under
four hundred thousand dollars a year
relative to historical levels
Republicans say that's not in the bill
but if her promises do hold up
additional enforcement would largely
Target Rich tax cheats as for
Republicans Bill to repeal the new IRS
funding the Congressional budget office
says it would add 114 billion dollars to
the deficit generating additional
Revenue with the White House veto threat
and a Democratic Senate the bill has no
way forward but it is a sign of things
to come as House Republicans plan to
pass legislation that will run into the
White House's red lines we're going to
pass bills to fix the nation's earns
challenges from wide open Southern
borders
to American last energy policies to woke
indoctrination in our schools pretty
good border we all think a border is
good right even Joe Biden now apparently
thinks that a border is good American
Energy that would be nice that might
help our economic situation get in the
woke stuff out all good again I don't
have any Illusions they will fail on
some of this stuff the Senate is not
going to go along with all this stuff
but they're trying and when good people
try you gotta back them uh I really want
to say good people when someone's out
there trying like hearing what the
issues are and then voted in and then
they're they're just at least are
showing you a glimmer of hope they're
trying to say hey boy I'm gonna actually
go to the promised land then you gotta
you gotta help them get there they're
shifting they're going on offense and
they're taking No Reservations about it
foreign
[Music]